hey guys and welcome back to the channel
as you can see I am back in the US back
in Chicago and uh it seems uh my travels
have caused me a bad case of ligma my
throat is hurting a bit at the moment so
I'm going to try and get through this
video decently fast and uh yeah let's go
ahead and talk about how we would
calculate the number of unique active
users on a site at a given time okay so
today we're going to be calculating the
number of unique users on a site between
a given time range so for example if uh
I have my own fans site over here very
real in fact and I have the following uh
list of things that I'm willing to sell
one question that I might have that I
want to ask only fans is how many
different unique users viewed this
content between last week and this week
I might be making a ton of money but if
it's just one of two one or two of you
guys that's buying everything uh you
know that's not looking good for the
future it would be better if I had
plenty of different people looking at my
page cool so let's actually formalize
some problem requirements here so number
one is that want to be able to calculate
the number of active users on a site so
that could be for just a given instant
or also just any possible time range
which is going to make this a bit more
complex number two is that a user can be
online at multiple devices at the same
time or have multiple different sessions
at the same time cool and then I'm not
going to go too crazy into the capacity
estimates we'll touch upon those a
little bit later in the video uh but the
gist is we can have billions of sessions
active at one time on a variety of
different
devices cool so the first thing that I
want to touch upon is just some
terminology or a paradigm overview that
I'm going to use for uh basically
building out the foundation of this
video so the idea that I want to uh
describe is the concept of a session
where when a user logs in on a given
device that device uh login is assigned
a particular session and when they're no
longer active on that device we should
keep track of the fact that that session
is no longer active it has been
completed so the way that we're going to
at least attempt to assign all of these
sessions is via something that I will
dub the session service so the session
service is going to do the following
when I log in it's just going to assign
me some sort of ID for the session
doesn't really matter if this is a uu ID
doesn't matter if it's a monotonically
increasing sequence number what's
important to me really is just that that
session number is going to be unique per
user so that when I'm looking eventually
per user I can actually just go ahead
and quickly confirm uh that this is you
know a new session and not a previous
one cool so the way that we can pretty
easily do that is um you know let's say
our session service is partitioned and
we have a sessions database which is
also partitioned by user ID basically
when I first log in the session service
can reach out to the database the
database will assign me a new session ID
based on the primary key and then we can
go ahead and just use that for the
duration of this session cool and then
so what would that look like well I've
drawn out a small diagram down here
we've got some load balancer the load
balancer is going to assign me to a
session service based on uh my user id
we just use consisten hashing and then
similarly again we have another load
balancer between the session service and
the actual sessions database because
this is going to be a pretty big table
uh if every session ever is going to be
in there so we're going to need a lot of
partitions and we can just do that based
again on user ID or rather the hash of
the user ID cool so what would that
table actually look like well we would
have our user field our session ID field
the start time and the end time of the
session and I'm assuming that if there
is no end time of a session that means
the session is still going to be in
progress so the nice thing we can do
here is also just index by session ID so
that way we can quickly query all the
sessions through all time and they're
going to be ordered by start time
effectively
cool the next thing we want to talk
about is session expiration so we just
described how when I log in I can be
assigned a new session for my device but
now we also have to talk about well if I
haven't been doing anything or the
server hasn't detected any activity from
me it has to consider me logged out
because I'm not always explicitly going
to log out sometimes I'll just close my
browser close my computer and then we're
not going to hear from me anymore so the
main idea is basically that every once
in a while I should probably be sending
some sort of heartbeat to the session
server indicating that I'm logged in or
that I'm active and then the gist from
here is that the session server can
effectively just keep track of which
heartbeats it's received order those by
the received Tim stamp that it got them
and then run a background process saying
ooh here are all of the session IDs that
I haven't received heartbeats for within
a certain amount of time that means I
should probably go ahead and consider
them expired let me go ahead and write
the end time to the database indicating
that that session has been completed
cool so the data structure that we can
use here is one that we've seen plenty
in the past we can use something like a
doubly linked list with a hashmap so
that we can quickly go ahead and order
and uh basically remove uh the session
IDs as we receive the new heartbeat and
then put them at the end of the doubly
link list so this is going to make all
of our accesses and and moves throughout
that W link list o of1 and uh yeah
should keep things relatively efficient
so again that back back ground process
is just going to the EXP expire the
sessions that we don't see heartbeats
for so for example if I have a user 11 a
session 4 and that's pinging our server
every 10 seconds and user 12 with
Session 9 decides to stop pinging maybe
after 30 seconds the session server is
going to say ooh I don't see that
anymore let me go ahead and put the
current time as the end time for that
session so the next thing that we're
going to do is very typical uh Jordan
Behavior which is obviously I'm going to
take all of the changes going to that
sessions database and use that as change
data capture the reason being that I
want to consume it Downstream and build
derived data off of it so from our
session database partition over here we
can basically take the changes on every
single given partition put that into a
partition on Kafka effectively meaning
that Kafka is also going to be sharded
on our user ID and then finally uh throw
that into Flink again meaning that it
would effectively be sharded on user ID
and then from Flink we can create all
sorts of derived data and insights that
we wouldn't have been able to do
otherwise by virtue of being able to run
custom code again of course I always end
up using Flink because uh I know that
state is getting checkpointed so I don't
really have to worry about dealing with
the fall tolerance as much here and uh
yeah just the fact that everything in
Kafka is durable means that I'm really
not worried too much about things going
down so the question now becomes well if
I'm going to use Flink to maintain some
State and then ultimately create derived
data from our sessions database what
derive data do I want to be creating and
so before I can go ahead and uh make any
claims there first I would like to show
off a few different ways that we can
actually go ahead and calculate the
number of unique active users so the
first way that I'm going to demonstrate
is what I would call the naive
calculation so let's say that we want to
find the number of unique users that
we've seen active at any time between
108 and 123 so this is our start and our
end time right here so we're basically
going to have to do uh three different
checks and then combine them all into
one set so the first thing that we need
to do is find any sessions that
basically started after 108 or started
before 123 meaning that you know this
would be a good example right there um
because then we're going to be active
during that window another option for a
session that we would include is one
that started before 108 but actually the
end time is between 108 and 123 so
that's option two and then option three
which is also possible is ooh we start
all the way back here and then we end
after 123 as well so if you think about
it this is actually going to be a little
bit complex the first two cases that we
just mentioned are relatively easy to
solve with indexes right if I order
every single session that I have by
their start time and then I create a
second index ordering every single
session that I have by their end time I
can easily binary search through just
checking for the range that I care about
that being said if I have a criteria
that is both filtering on the start time
as well as the end time one single index
on either the start time or the end Time
Field is not going to be good enough for
us it's actually the same problem that
we see when we try to query by
geolocation data effectively I can very
easily find all start times before 108
but there's no good filtering method for
me to combine that with all end times
after 123 which is not so easy in theory
we could combine both indexes and do a
join but that could potentially make for
a gigantic join and that could be very
inefficient one option that you may be
thinking about here if you are thinking
about the two-dimensional index problem
would be that we could in theory use
something like a multi-dimensional or
almost like a geolocation index here uh
but personally I think that uh becomes a
bit Overkill and I'll talk a little bit
more about how I want to solve this
problem
otherwise cool so now the next thing
that we're going to be talking about is
calculating the unique number of active
users a little bit better so that we
don't have to scan over a ton of data
and consider all of these different
sessions so let's imagine that we had
snapshots of active sessions at a bunch
of discret points of time right so let's
say this example that I'm going to do
below we take one every 5 minutes so now
from these discret snapshots we may
actually be able to figure out all of
the sessions that were active during a
given time range and then of course from
all the sessions we just take all the
distinct user IDs so let's say at 105
we've got the following snapshot you
know user 12 has session a user 12 on a
different device also has session B and
then user 13 also has session
a now we see all of our session
snapshots listed Out Below cool and
basically all we would really do is take
the union of all of the users across all
of those snapshots with a couple of
small edge cases so the first is that
for a guy like this 13A for example we
can see that 13A is no longer around in
the 110 snapshot meaning we actually
have to go ahead and check the exact
start and end time of uh you know user
13 session a so that we make sure that
it actually ended after 108 and not you
know before 108 ending at 107 because
then we wouldn't want to count it and we
would have to do the same thing with
this guy over here 14c we can see that
it was existent at 125 but does that
mean that it started before
123 or after 123 it's hard to say we
would have to actually go ahead and uh
cross reference with our sessions
database which actually has that
information available so then we're
going to merge all of the user IDs into
one single set and this is going to be
quite a bit more efficient because now
we're actually just reading from a
limited set of snapshots as opposed to
having to do a potential scan over all
possible session IDs of all time which
if you think about it you're basically
looking at every single user session on
your website which has billions of users
that's going to be very inefficient that
being said this guy still has quite a
few problems as well which we're going
to cover in the next slide so there are
two main problems basically the first is
this if we're reading for many session
snapshots keep in mind each session
snapshot could be pretty big right we're
talking about potentially billions of
active sessions in a given moment we're
going to be reading lots of duplicate
data and that is going to be bad so for
example uh you know user 12 was active
on session B at both 105 110 115 and 120
and so now we're reading that data four
different times we only wanted to read
it once so this is going to be a bit
Overkill and more importantly the
previous solution isn't actually correct
so why is that well if we're only taking
snapshots every 5 minutes what if a user
was active right here in between two
snapshots then we're never even going to
get word that they their session existed
in the first place and we're never going
to see them and now we're going to
undercount so that's going to be a
problem too so what can we actually do
both to ensure ideally better
performance but also most importantly
correctness well we're going to need to
take some sort of hybrid approach
between both our snapshotting solution
as well as our actual linear scan
solution so here's the way that I've
come up up with that I think would uh
would do this in uh The Kind of Perfect
accurate solution way which is let's
imagine we have our snapshots still
every 5 minutes and right now we're only
going to care about the snapshots that
are just outside of the time range that
we care about because we want to make
sure we incorporate every possible
solution so in this case we've got one
at 105 which is the first snapshot
before 108 and we've got one at 125
which is the first snapshot after
123 so the first thing that we're going
to do is we're going to get all of our
sessions with a start time between 105
and 125 we know how to do that if we
have a database index on all of our
sessions we can easily do this
calculation it's just a range query same
thing with all of our ends note that uh
we're doing 105 to 125 the reason being
that someone could be active from 106 to
124 and that wouldn't be reflected in
our snapshot data over here so we
actually have to query the entire range
between our two snapshots and then once
we consider all of those potenti
sessions then we can actually use our
snapshots themselves so now we're going
to go ahead and take a look at all of
our active sessions at 105 for example
we've got user 12 active on session a
and user 13 active on session B now even
though we know that these guys were
active at 105 we now have to ask
ourselves ooh was this session still
going at 108 and the only way that we
can actually determine that is by
figuring out their start and end times
and probably going back to our session
database to go ahead and do that cross
reference
the other thing is that basically you
know for all of our sessions that are
intersecting from 108 to 123 so
basically that's going to be all the
valid sessions from here all the valid
sessions from here all the valid
sessions from here and all the valid
sessions from here now we basically have
to uh go ahead and keep all of the user
IDs that we saw that were distinct count
them up and return that to the user so
cool that is actually how we would go
ahead and do this what would this look
like from implementation details and
the the actual technical perspective
here so in order to actually do this
we've now mentioned three different
types of derived data right we need
basically one index to index all of our
sessions by their start and their end
time it doesn't necessarily have to be a
perfect index but ideally some sort of
partition table where the partitions are
aligning nicely with the start and end
times of the session and that way we can
really quickly find all of the sessions
that have a given start time or have a
given end time so that's uh basically
two different tables that we need to
maintain uh we can do this by just using
some time series database and
partitioning it properly uh so that we
can easily go ahead and get these
sessions ideally or rather unfortunately
there is probably going to be a lot of
data so it's possible that even for a
given time range we're going to need a
couple of different partitions but
that's okay uh ultimately it's going to
be a distributed read on an immutable
table and uh what can you do cool number
two is that uh we need to be able to
find the active sessions based on the
discrete timestamp right so effectively
these are our session session snapshots
so in the above example it's you know
something like this at 105 which
sessions were active so the way that we
can actually go ahead and do this is by
using Flink again so Flink what it'll do
is it'll basically keep track of all the
newly created sessions which it'll get
through change data capture and
basically it'll keep those buffered in
its own memory it's all partition so we
should be able to do this relatively
easily and then basically every few
minutes Flink will look at all of the
active sessions for which it sees a
start time but not an end time and then
basically snapshot those over to a
database additionally what it'll do is
if the end time does come in for a given
session indicating that that session is
completed Flink will then just remove it
from its memory so in subsequent
snapshots that session won't be present
so hopefully that all makes sense and
then ideally what we could do is
actually publish back to my SQL that way
we can get nice joins on the snapshot
data with the actual official start and
end time of each session however in
reality it's possible this may end up
being too much data we may have to put
these snapshots in something like hdfs
uh via parket files and uh if we have to
end up doing that what can you do it'll
be slow but uh such is
life cool so now let's go ahead and talk
about some of these problems with
snapshotting because you know I've I've
spoken about these snapshots like
they're super easy to make and the truth
is they're not that hard to make but
objectively it is a ton of data right
because at the end of the day if we want
to take a snapshot saying at X time
which sessions were active well we need
the user ID and the session ID for every
single active session and this could be
like a billion at a time so keep in mind
that the user ID and the session ID
alone are probably 16 bytes because each
of them is probably eight bytes if we
want to represent them with a long and
then from there let's imagine we have a
billion active sessions at a time this
means each snapshot itself is a whole 16
GB of data now the problem with that is
that let's say we're taking one of these
snapshots a minute that means every
single hour We're publishing a terabyte
of data and if we're publishing a
terabyte per hour that means we're
basically publishing 9 to 10 pedabytes
of data per year now look realistically
if you're Google if you're Microsoft if
you're Amazon you can probably afford
that and it's not a huge deal but
depending on how many services you're
actually doing it for maybe you do want
to save those storage costs or just in
general the actual cost of buffering
everything in memory because that can be
kind of expensive too like keep in mind
that we do have all of these different
Flink nodes to take the snapshots and
that's not necessarily an easy thing to
do it means we're going to be using a
lot of ram to actually buffer all of
these different sessions so even though
we can handle this if we want to make
things cheaper and potentially faster uh
a lot of companies have opted to begin
using approximation methods here to
actually do this in a little bit of a
better way so we'll discuss that in a
second so if you've watched my 1.0
series uh you'll probably imagine that I
am talking about the hyper log log so
the hyper log log is a probabilistic
data structure
that allows us to compute the
cardinality which basically just means
the number of distinct elements within a
set and the the whole point here is
ideally we want to be doing this with
relatively low memory usage so that we
can stick this on any given server and
easily compute uh the cardinality of all
of our given active users in a given
moment cool so how does this actually
work well let's imagine I take a given
user ID and I represent it in binary so
you can see I have 32 bits here so the
first thing that we're going to do is do
the following we're going to assign the
first few bits
for something called bucketing which
means we're going to bucket all of these
user IDs into different buckets based on
what those first few bits are and then
the other thing we care about are the
number of leading zeros at the end of
the number so in this case we've got
five at the end of our user ID cool so
in the way hyper log log is going to
work is as follows let's say we have a
100 different user IDs that have come in
that are potentially active at the
moment basically the first thing that
we're going to do is bucket each one
into multiple different buckets based on
those bucketing bits the next thing that
we're going to do is find the user idid
in each bucket with the maximum number
of leading zeros so in this case it's
five for this user ID but you know maybe
in a given bucket there might be seven
leading zeros for one user ID what we're
then going to do is each bucket is going
to you know take that user ID with the
maximum number of leading zeros so maybe
bucket one has three bucket two has five
we're going to average those numbers
together right so three and five the
average would be four so that we're
going to call that X and then the
cardinality of the entire set is going
to be 2 to the X so in this case 2 4
which is 16 so let me make this a little
bit more
concrete basically let's say we've got
the following buckets right we've got
our user IDs from both buckets if I look
for the user ID with the maximum number
of leading zeros in bucket one it's
going to be this guy here with three
leading zeros bucket two it's this guy
here with five leading zeros we're going
to average those together take two to
that power and that's going to estimate
that there are 16 elements in this set
now clearly as you can see there are
only going to be eight elements in this
set it's a probabilistic data structure
but the more buckets that you have the
better estimates this guy is going to
create and ultimately that's going to be
a nice thing now I'm not going to go too
deep into any of the mathematical
guarantees about this probabilistic data
structure because frankly I think for us
software Engineers it doesn't really
matter as much as long as you understand
the general idea which is basically
saying oh you know if I've seen enough
user IDs that one of them has five
leading zeros well there's a good shot
that there were probably 32 of them
because you know then my expected value
of you know seeing such a user ID uh is
is checking out so again if you care
more about the mathematical stuff here
go look up hyper log log on Wikipedia
there's plenty you can read about it uh
but yeah hopefully the intuition makes a
little bit of sense
here so the question now becomes well
how do we want to build our hyper log
logs the idea here is you know every
certain uh time granularity or time
period we want to be taking another one
of these hyper log logs the reason being
that you actually can't remove elements
from these hyper log logs the idea is
just that you know within each bucket
we're not actually storing all of these
user IDs what we're just storing is the
number of leading zeros the biggest
number and so in this case we would just
be storing bucket one is three bucket
two is five if we store all of the user
IDs then we could actually go ahead and
remove elements but we don't want to do
that because the whole point is to use
as little space as
possible great so like I mentioned you
can't really remove elements from a
hyper log log so every time our interval
uh begins again every time say our
minute passes and we want to get a new
snapshot what we need to do is just
completely clear out our old hyper log
log and build it up from scratch so the
question now becomes well if we want one
snapshot per minute then we have to
clear out our hyper log log how do we
actually know which user IDs become
active again because the user ID is
already logged in like it's not going to
our hyper log log and saying hey add me
back again add me back so instead what
we could do is actually do this on our
session server itself the reason being
that our session server is actually
receiving pings from every user So based
on receiving a ping we can then add that
user ID back to our hyper log log which
is going to be pretty nice we can do all
of that bucketing on each session server
partition and then let's say our minute
passes we want to take a snapshot we
would go compute that average over all
of the buckets throw that in a hyper log
log database and then you know across
all of the session server partitions we
could also take that average there if we
wanted to so for example you know in
reality I would have session server
one and session server 2 and they would
both be exporting here and then when we
read back eventually we can just perform
that average let's say there are 10
session servers overall or even a 100 of
them you're just averaging 100 numbers
that's not an expensive computation for
a database
cool so the next thing is uh just
actually going ahead and reading our
hyper log logs uh from all these
snapshots I'm just going to quickly
demonstrate how we might perform in
approximation in reality it's probably a
bit more nuanced than this but again I I
just don't want to go into the math too
much uh not only because I'm incapable
of it but also I think it's out of scope
for a video like this so let's imagine
again we care about all of the number of
unique active users from 108 to
123 and we have all of these hyper log
log sketches so you know the there's
three zeros for the 105 there's four
zeros for the 110 5 zeros for the 115
three zeros again at 120 and 5 zeros at
125 this is five different sketches so
we take the aage across all of them take
the sum note that this sums out to four
leading zeros out of our biggest user ID
and so we're going to now estimate that
there were 16 users in this time so
basically we're just going to be merging
our hyper log logs together from all the
different intervals and uh taking our
best guess of course this is an
approximation uh but we don't care as
long as it's approximate uh enough and
accurate enough uh then this should
suffice and it's also just going to be a
lot cheaper because now we don't have to
buffer all of these user IDs in memory
on a a bunch of different Flink
notes cool so I'm going to now put this
all together in one single diagram
ideally and uh that is going to look
like the following if we have our user
over here when the user logs on they're
going to reach out to a load balancer
which based on their user ID is going to
connect them to a given session service
from the session service we are now
going to reach out to a session database
which is just an easy MySQL table this
is not going to be written to that much
that I think uh MySQL is going to
completely fine and we can Shard this
guy on user ID using primary key
constraints to ensure that our session
ID is not one that we've used before for
that user is it possible that a user
could create a thousand sessions in like
a minute and we could overload MySQL
maybe but if they are they're probably
malicious and uh I wouldn't mind if
their query was slow anyway this is what
we have things like rate limiters for we
should just stop them from creating that
many sessions that fast so yeah I do
think it's fine to have uh one user ID
per Shard ultimately or not not one user
ID per Shard but basically every single
user belongs to just one Shard so yeah
we we assign them that uh session ID and
then from there all of that data from
the MySQL table is flowing through Kafka
uh via change data capture keep in mind
the session service is also responsible
for expiring sessions so if for whatever
reason I stop pinging my session service
the session service will then reach back
out to the session database saying hey
this thing has gone ahead and ended uh
and again that is now going to flow back
through Kafka as well and into our Flink
noes so in Flink assuming we're not
doing the hyper log log approach and
we're just doing our you know our
perfect solution where we have all these
snapshots and uh you know we're trying
to basically export them at a given
interval what Flink is going to be doing
is the following it's going to say
something like okay for user 12 session
a this guy is currently open and I have
yet to see an end time from my SQL if an
end time comes in indicating the session
is done I just delete this from memory
and so now let's say I've 13B available
and 14 user 14 with session C let's say
that minute comes along and it's time
for me to snapshot I'm going to take
this entire set and I'm just going to
throw it right back in the database so
that's going to go right back over here
to the session database ideally it can
fit because this is just going to be
limited basically by the uh the number
of users that are actually on that
partition of the database itself but if
it doesn't again just throw it in h dup
and we'll we'll have to deal with it
later so yeah put this back in the
session database in some different table
maybe call it the session snapshot table
and then that way we can quickly join
that with the actual session database to
get the start and end times of all of
these sessions because otherwise we'd
have to denormalize our data and that's
going to be pretty tough cool so that's
one thing that we're going to do is
publishing these active session
snapshots for a given timestamp the
other thing that we're going to do is be
syncing all of this data over to the
session start time index and the session
end time index so as we mentioned in
terms terms of how we want to get our
exact solution it's pretty imperative
that we can quickly figure out uh you
know if I have a given time stamp I can
quickly figure out all of the sessions
that started within those two St
timestamps and all the sessions that
ended within those two timestamps and
the way that we can most easily do that
is just by building a Global index over
the session start Tim stamp and the
session end time stamp and uh we'll
probably need a lot of partitions here
because there are a lot of sessions uh
but as long as we're pretty smart about
doing that and make them granular enough
I think uh the work out pretty nicely
cool and then the last aspect of this
whole problem is going to be the actual
publishing of the hyper log logs so
again we're just going to be doing that
from our session Services each partition
or basically every horizontally scaled
instance of our session service is
responsible for a few different user IDs
or a range of user IDs based on the hash
of them and we can go ahead and compute
the hll locally on each one of those and
then publishing that number per session
service on an interval to the hyper log
l snapshot database I think this is
another thing that would also be fine as
a Time series database but again there's
not that much data use whatever database
you please and then the final piece of
the puzzle is just going to actually be
reading the metrics so for the active
user service if we want just an
approximate calculation all we have to
do is read from the hyper log log
snapshot database accordingly as I
showed in this slide over here that
being said if we want an exact count and
we don't really care how long it takes
us to get it what we probably want to do
is read from both the session start
index the session end index and then
also our session snapshots which could
either be in hdfs or in my SQL but
ultimately we're going to have to join
those with the MySQL data to figure out
the exact start and end time of all of
the sessions in the session snapshot
okay guys I hope this one made a little
bit of sense my voice is only hurting me
a little bit so that's a positive but uh
yeah I'm going to go ahead and get
myself to the gym and I will see you in
the next one